jay hughes dead  and here i thought nothing would cheer  me up today great  consider the gig closed  foreign  as you know kabuki's got a new fixer  from the ussr  been running some major biz in nc for a  few weeks now  not sure what exactly but we're gonna  find out you need to clip his data shard  it's got everything more on our comrade  and the gig in the attachment  how am i supposed to know you already  owe me a lot bro  yeah everyone knows about your city  listen i gotta get back to work  well  [Music]  so  [Music]  uh  is  [Music]  oh  [Music]  uh keep firing god dammit  um  so  uh  oh  yeah when you get there no questions  makes them real cranky try my best  [Music]  you need for  solar